it's a fool a Capcom exclusive point
three-man Ready Set Radio in the middle
of that funk volume take over we have
got named the guy who runs the label
he's here we also got busy writers oh
yeah yeah this is art this time I gotta
ask you guys about something was brought
to my attention a few weeks ago maybe a
month ago because I'm in Arizona and I'm
a fan of what you guys do and I support
you know dizzy and the whole label as
far as our Sunday night show you know um
there's some guy out here named the
Joker
yo really I literally when someone's
like yo there's a guy in Arizona who
don't lose beefs with those guys because
I was like I said something about
futuristic you know he's from AZ and you
guys work together and then somebody who
wasn't really hip to the Scituate was
like nah I don't think futuristic life's
dizzy right he was dissing him all right
what there's some guy out here that's
just this all he does is dysfunctional
and this Joker dude and he literally
every single song that he makes is
dissing [__] buddy no it's not a bad
rapper though no no but listen listen
not every single video everything is
dedicated to it's like a free promotion
yeah yeah it's crazy like I've never
seen like an obsession like because yo I
think the guy can rap like when I hear a
rap dude got bars you know you know he
dresses like a big-ass Joker but he
literally just disses funk like I don't
I don't get the I don't know marketing
plan in that but you could probably make
some music Regis setback and focus on
his music but but now I want to know
like what do you guys like when that
time stuff happens like we talked about
you beef with somebody before snapping
awesome dude why you sitting on the
owner washing machine you know how do
you guys feel about stuff like that
because I just think it's I wanna say
pathetic but it's kind of yeah I don't
like it when it's corny like that right
like my like my little beat that I have
was kind of personal just
homey I started doing my thing you have
yeah I'm saying you know I'm saying yeah
people are nailing the city yeah for
this dude this was hops friend like this
was one of hops little buddies and I had
met him like one time at the hot madness
video shoot and that's the only time I
met him and then after that he was just
going in see what I don't get is is like
I apparently his because Hobson is
really really don't like your ass he
don't not [__] with any men oh but I
just don't understand like from what
from what I gather the dude is trying to
say that you're just a weed rapper and
my head and I'm like darn have you heard
Disney like talks about God in a box me
he's positive you don't like like that's
not even like I would even say that
that's close to the majority that's I
mean but Dane like you when you're going
to have this guy go before we're heavily
involved with our fans and severe
interactive online and I think that you
know a lot of people get too invested in
in that stuff and start to think that
they know us personally but this person
did know hot person right it was not a
friend of mine but he's definitely a
friend of pops
you know the hops from the internet
world too you know there's a lot of
miscommunications that can happen when
you're going in and out of the internet
world to you know to reality and back
and forth three commercials yeah I mean
I don't mean have you seen like the
merch that it's kind of like low-key
jacking your guys yeah that's why I say
like lawsuit is it's corny like that
it's like you know what we do this this
this uh rap competition you don't funk
up our beats and life pretty much people
who do good videos and get good
responses if they don't win they get
salty right right like people by the way
the guy who won this this this year I
wasn't that impressed by we still have
and there's a lot there's judges judges
yes so hard but I think like the other
guys who were like in the running and it
was dumped you understand but yeah and I
like that contest is it's a way to you
know it's real smart he was a part of
that contest right yeah that's what kind
that's one ask miss bart's fear because
he didn't he didn't win first yeah in
salt and he just when artist but he
wanted to be demo everybody think they
know hot is right yeah you having a man
exactly have in your mind at you the
hottest and then you have label around
you maybe even a small following online
if you the hottest then in your mind
just cemented that you should be that
guy nothing but yes ma'am do you sir
thank you you think I mean I think right
now you guys are in a good place little
wise like are you even looking to sign
anybody right now is that even something
that's like you know still I mean you
guys think that you kind of got the
starting for right now yeah I think this
year will have another artist okay
by the end of the year we should have
somebody else do you think judging the
contest is hard bringing somebody on the
label is that's hard is that thousand
times
yeah right futuristic is ready though I
really is where I really [__]
futuristic he that he that guy yeah he's
not our support 100% you know on the
label or not man we post the stuff
except this phone calls hey that's a
start though you take a vote that's a
start yeah hey dizzy who are horse and
collapse your sophomore album that like
you say you had Alaric labs in the can
but like what's like the two or three
you know obtainable kind of dream
collabs I'm not asking you to say Andre
3000 of jay-z's I don't think you're
there yet
right what I'm saying like right now oh
don't think of somebody that you could
realistically I don't know bro like I'm
really like I don't know man I'm just
going with the flow like I'm not really
like pressing for anything I'm just like
if somebody got talent and there's like
a time where I [__] with them or
whatever and I
I can see you gettin with bone I think I
definitely I'm definitely gonna get with
ball and I'm definitely not gonna get
with bone for my mixtape that's a lie if
you guys definitely album a future yeah
make sure and stuff make sure dizzy her
of busy-busy is uh you know couple days
sold before you select a picked a busy
bone in Boise Idaho at an airport in
like a hey Accord you know it was own
one
I thought no you like I thought this
dude was gonna kill him you know I
remember when I was uh I think I was ten
years old I was with lazybone and we
went we went to pick up what were you
doing with lazy boy when you were 10
years old I'm just curious
oh wait your mom mom okay that's right
my man yes so mom not still writing raps
though right now right she'd be trying
to write your raps yeah my mom is not a
super super posit your mom is great man
you know what's crazy is like when I was
in Vegas doing radio I remember your mom
would tweet me all the time she's
serious she going oh yeah I think your
sister just dropped a clothing line -
right yeah my sister just realized a
little high life care but sorry so we
got to make the bone clap you already
kind of have that you know yeah yeah the
bone the bone stuff yeah I remember I
was with lazybone when I was a youngster
and I remember we went to to the airport
I just rolled with him to pick up busy
and it was the Fertile and busy first
cut his hair oh boy oh really crazy haha
we passed here you got a layout busy man
yo we not I love busy like nothing -
dude you just I love everything about
you but he was buying it and we didn't
even recognize him and it was just wow
he got in the car tripping out something
about why cut his hair and he was his
trip you're 10 years old yeah
it was loud it was like hair stains like
everybody had hair like I hear all my
brothers had hair bone like you know
always no further yeah just like the
whole hair stays like alright well we
definitely support funk volume over here
man the new album from Jared is the next
project dropping in June or July okay so
make sure you go pick that up my
grandma's basement the single is crazy
dizzy rights gonna be coming out in the
mixtape soon indeed he's torn with a
bunch of stoner Caucasians right now
know much about knocking indeed I am and
yo man
prepare to be like uh embraced by their
entire fanbase for the rest of your life
oh man if you oppress them on stage
their fans forever bro and that's
exactly why I'm doing this man that's
that's a smart move
most people would be like most right
like if like most rappers would be right
they got they got a foundation they're
doing they've been doing there anything
with sudden there's records for years
and years Dame um what is next for funk
volume you got a new artist hopefully
maybe this year we'll get a new artist
signed to the label have you light
linked up and spoke with cuz I feel like
you guys are kind of I want to say taken
but kind of like strange music kind of
set the blueprint for this indie hip hop
thing and I write with you know as far
as building a fanbase and stuff and I
thought you guys are doing it the 2013
sounds right
no I learned a lot from them I know
Travis I know Tech now you know I
definitely take a lot from what from
what they've done and just kind of put a
new source new a new kind of spin on it
and doing it our way kind of branching
out so that we don't get put in a one
particular box so I just want to stay
open to all all potential opportunities
hey do you have a name for the new tape
yeah I do um the name of the new takers
to go to names good Golden Age I like
that yeah the Golden Age for you though
was like what like 98 yeah 90s
golden age is pretty much like the
eighties in the nineties I know that but
I'm saying like me young yeah
like 97 9
ei cuz how are you did you like 2222
yeah the rabbit says use eight men sows
eight years old
boom look it up on YouTube man you see
is doing 106 and park flashing that
thing for the community be fried I'm
sure trying to bring back the jerk
movement just cuz you know why though
because like that like the whole jerk
movement it's so crazy because it went
to a crazy phase to where the little
kids kind of took it open it and skinny
jeans and bright colors good bright
colors first it was some hood [__] it
was a two-step it was to step that the
6o crimp started man and it was just
like that's what it came a new boy chain
man pretty much it pretty much went
through a little kid phase through the
whole world and now people look at the
jerk move man like but I still remember
that like them days where it was like
all boogie and it was just like a super
boogie you know I'm saying so it
probably won't happen because all the
little kids being a part of it but it
was though that's I can't even play
you're a jerk roll me in the club
anymore anyway last question man um what
do you want your legacy to be man like
you're I feel like in 2013 you know you
don't need a major label you don't need
you you like you've been doing what you
want and that's probably the reason why
you but like you know everybody wants to
be the biggest rapper in the world be
known as one of the Great's what what is
something that you you know what would
be consenting with one day living back
in your career yeah there's been a
legendary just being one of the greats
just you know somebody we just put in a
super work I want you know the kids now
and saying here's to be like yo Disney
when he first got the double XL cover
images go you know this is my jay-z
early days right you know reasonable
down time right now yeah it's like the
times that you know you have to be here
to really be able to witness and love it
and you don't even know what's going on
right thank you
like right now is the beginning when you
look mad actually and I think that's
what makes the legendary just being
humble to it but I just want always you
know
for being a white legend very humble and
cool are the funk volume groupies there
they gotta be cuter than the than the
ICPs groupies right I don't know like my
like don't gotta know cute female my
boobies is a little cute adapts as
groupies but then getting cuter by the
day no there's a so I know you said
smash a couple rampages on sort of
Kottonmouth Kings with yo tapes coming
soul poomp I appreciate y'all coming
through man it's power 98.3 race that
radio cool me appreciate it